DAVID SHIROKOFF: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
So today I'd like to take a
look at gain and phase lag.
And we're going to consider
this simple problem.
So first off, find a periodic
solution to x dot dot plus 8x
dot plus 7x equals F_0
times cosine omega*t.
So basically, it's just
forcing a differential equation
with some frequency
cosine omega t.
And the problem we're
interested in today
is to give the gain and phase
lag to this periodic solution.
So I'll let you take a look at
this problem and I'll be back
in a minute.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
OK, so we're interested in
finding this periodic solution
to the differential equation.
And we see here that we're
forcing it with right-hand side
of cosine omega*t.
So the standard procedure
is to first complexify.
So we're going to consider the
differential equation x dot dot
plus 8x dot plus 7x equals
F_0 e to the i*omega*t.
And then at the end,
we're going to take
the real part of our solution
to this differential equation.
And we do this because cosine
omega*t is the real part of e
to the i omega t.
Now, for this equation,
we see that we're
forcing it with an exponential.
So we can just use the
exponential response formula.
And this gives us a
particular solution.
So the exponential response
formula is 1 over p of i*omega
times the right-hand side,
which is F_0 e to the i*omega*t.
And in this case, the
characteristic polynomial,
p of s, is s squared
plus 8s plus 7.
So that p of i*omega is going
to be 7 minus omega squared--
so the omega squared comes
from s squared-- plus 8i*omega.
Now, I'd just like
to take a moment
and step back for a second.
If we take a look at the
differential equation,
the input on the right-hand
side is F_0 e to the i*omega*t.
Now notice how this
characteristic-- sorry,
the exponential response formula
gives us a particular solution,
which is 1 over p of i*omega
F_0 e to the i*omega*t,
which is a periodic solution.
But moreover, the output
of this formula shows that
it's actually the input forcing
multiplied by this factor 1
over p of i*omega.
So this factor right
here, 1 over p of i omega
relates the input forcing
to the output forcing.
Or sorry, to the
output response.
And this factor is sometimes
called the complex gain.
And the reason it's the complex
gain is because if we take
a look at p of i*omega, it has
a real part and an imaginary
part.
So specifically, p of
i*omega contains two pieces
of information.
Because it's a
complex number, we
can think of it as being
an amplitude and a phase.
So the amplitude of p of
i*omega is It's sometimes called
the gain.
And the phase of p of
i*omega is the phase lag.
So p of i*omega contains
two pieces of information,
which relate the input forcing
signal to the output response
of the differential equation.
Now, I'd like to go ahead and
write x of t, decomplexify.
So we're going to take the real
part of 1 over p of i*omega
times F_0 e to the i*omega*t.
So we have 7 minus omega
squared plus 8i*omega.
Upstairs is F_0 e
to the i*omega*t.
And I'm going to just put
this in amplitude-phase form.
And when I take the real part,
I'll do it in two steps first.
8 omega squared.
Square rooted.
F_0 e to i*omega*t
divided by e to the i*phi.
Where here phi is the
phase lag and tangent phi
is going to be the imaginary
part over the real part.
And just quickly note that as
omega goes from 0 to infinity,
tangent phi will
go from 0 to pi.
So this is the range of phi
that we're interested in.
And now, when we
take the real part,
we end up with F_0 1 over 7
minus omega squared quantity
squared plus 8 omega
squared, all squared rooted,
cosine omega*t minus phi.
And now we'd like to look at
what the amplitude and phase
are as a function of omega.
So for each fixed
omega, the output
is going to be a
sinusoid which oscillates
at the same frequency
as the input.
However, the only difference
is that it's going
to have a rescaled amplitude.
And it will have a
shifted phase as well.
So for the amplitude response,
we're interested in plotting 1
over the amplitude
of p of i*omega.
So here's the amplitude.
And this function is just going
to decrease and asymptotically
approach infinity.
So this is the
amplitude response.
This is 1 over 7 minus
omega squared square rooted
plus 8omega squared,
quantity square rooted.
This is omega.
And then in addition to
the amplitude response,
we also have the phase.
And the phase, if I go
back up here for a second,
we can write it
explicitly as phi
is equal to tan inverse 8omega
divided by 7 minus omega
squared.
So I'm going to plot omega on
this axis and phi on this axis.
And, OK, so to plot this curve,
we note that when omega is 0,
tan inverse of 0 is 0.
So we're going to start at 0.
Typically, what I usually
like to do in this case
is look at the denominator
in the arctangent.
We see that when omega is
equal to the square root of 7,
this argument blows up.
It goes to infinity.
And the arctangent of
infinity is pi over 2.
So I can draw a curve in
here, which is pi over 2.
So we know that phi is pi over
2 when omega is equal to root 7.
And note how this is the
natural frequency if there
was no damping in the system.
And then lastly, there's
another curve here at pi.
We see that as omega
approaches infinity, again,
this argument approaches 0.
And if you were to take the
derivative of this whole
quantity, we would see that
it's-- of tan inverse of this
argument, we would see that the
function's increasing for all
omega.
So it actually looks
something like this.
It looks like an s-shaped curve
that asymptotically approaches
pi as omega goes to infinity.
So just to quickly recap.
When we look at the
differential equation,
or a particular solution to
a differential equation which
is being forced by a
periodic sinusoidal function,
the output is always
going to be rescaled
and phase shifted,
but still oscillating
at the same frequency.
And specifically,
depending on which
frequency the differential
equation's forced at,
the amplitude will take
on different values.
The amplitude response will
take on different values.
And the phase shift will also
have different values depending
on the frequency of forcing.
So I'd just like
to conclude here,
and I'll see you next time.